juste car une petite petite parenthèse
bien triste puisqu'on vient d'apprendre
en direct
voilà que et ça va vous touchez comme
nous tous a forcément que pape diouf
l'ancien président de l'olympique de
marseille décédé du trône à virus
voilà c'était un passage faute de pape
diouf à lajunie on vient d'apprendre
on dirait que je sais que karim sall est
extrêmement de touché mais voilà je suis
très touchée et je pense qu'on va être
très nombreux à être très louche et de
la perte de cet homme de grande valeur
très très grande valeur qui nous avons
marqué à beaucoup d'entre nous moi je le
connaissais bien j'avais mené des
actions avec lui franchement c'est une
peine est énorme ici mais tu m'apprends
c'est indirect c'est énorme c'est
vraiment chiant mais moi je la prends
c'est en direct voilà j'étais très très
fan de pas de doute voilà qu'on appelait
vraiment c'était le lesage dans le
milieu du football
ancien président de l'olympique de
marseille et voilà donc ce coronavirus
qui fait encore des ravages
et c'est vrai que voilà avons se dit on
a envie de trouver des solutions
on a envie d'entendre des gens qui sont
porteurs d'espoir on a envie d'entendre
des personnes voilà qu'ils foutent aide
des essais qui essaie des choses et
comme vous l'avait dit il ya un instant
monsieur pérol
c'est vrai que voilà on dit là on est en
termes de médecine de guerre donc on
aimerait tous que ça avance très très
vite
voilà alors elle la question c'est
est-ce qu'il faut prendre des risques il
faut pas prendre de risques parce que
forcément là on voit des gens tomber
tous les jours encore voilà des gens là
on est plus en plus de proches aussi qui
sont touchés par la maladie du
coronavirus on vit mine de rien dans
l'angoissé
tous ici donc forcément je pense que les
téléspectateurs pensent pareil quand ils
entendent le professeur raoul voilà nous
dire qu'il a peut-être des bons
résultats avec un médicament bornes
envie de l'écouter on a envie de le
croire et n'a envie d'avoir de l'espoir